ron desantis has officially signed the
i guess what do you get what do you call
it the bill stripping disney of its
special privileges and the funny thing
about this is that he was surrounded by
children who were all cheering and
clapping and i just i just find that
very very funny so we'll talk about that
we'll talk about the conflict one of the
i think the craziest story today
actually was that marjorie taylor green
was testifying
in an in an administ administrative
trial to determine whether or not she
should be disqualified from re-election
which just says to me yo this is a sign
of the the collapse of the republic
robbie starbuck was booted uh was booted
off the the primary because the the
republican gob played some bs now you've
got them trying to squat the
establishment mind you it's not just
democrats it's republicans as well
trying to disqualify people like
marjorie taylor green and madison
cawthorne so here we go these people
know they're losing the elite know that
they're struggling to maintain a grip on
this country populism is rising up be it
left or right and now they're resorting
to dirty tricks to get their way you
know it just sounds sounds to me like
everything is falling apart so we'll
talk about that and we have this we have
this viral story going around about mike
pence in january 6.
it's it's the weirdest thing it's like
the left is accusing mike pence of being
in on a coup
because he refused to get into a car
so i don't know why this story is is for
some reason getting prominence now
because the story's actually very old
but we'll talk about it either way and
then uh some guy tried lighting himself
on fire from the supreme court we'll
talk about that too
joining us
on this uh wonderful and beautiful
friday is tina mcguinness and her
progeny richard
who wants to introduce themselves first
mom's first obviously
i am richard's mom can you pull your mic
up a little bit
i am richie mcginnis's mom so what do
you do
i am a mom
[Laughter]
very important role all right a working
mother though which is important all
mothers are working let's not get into
that
this is one of my major pet peeves about
that
expression working mother
all mothers work yeah but my mom worked
harder than others
[Laughter]
well with three boys you do work pretty
hard that's pretty sure so who is this
richard sitting over here uh richie
mcginnis uh she named me richard but i
won't i went with richie because my
uncle's richard
uh and i'm running for mayor of chicken
city that's right well actually sheriff
well sheriff and then i it's a hostile
takeover okay don't you just walk in and
seize it
once i get a hold of the arm so this is
it um our guest tonight's quite
literally some guy who wants to be in my
chicken coop and his mom
exactly
we're gonna have a great talk about
chickens and
elections yeah i like that you talked
about work because work scientifically
is like an uh an expression of energy uh
you can measure it in jewels and so like
right now we're working if you're
thinking you're producing work right so
this is just another kind of work
whether it's a job or not that you get
paid for is kind of irrelevant at that
point correct
uh i rolled a 30 you guys oh happy
friday thank you yeah let's get rocking
and that's ian and uh richie of course
is a i guess a journalist he's been on
on the ground for all of these major uh
moments of unrest risking his life in in
some instances to save lives so richie's
got tremendous experience dealing with
conflict crisis and the political much
to the anger of my mom yeah yeah
well that's that's why we thought it was
important to have your mom on so we
could all collectively scold you for
this dangerous line of work yes
it's a good thing i didn't know about
much of it yeah until it had already
happened
and her birthday is the insurrection oh
that's right
january 6 happy birthday imagination uh
i think uh something happened no he
changed the lyrics to the song it's now
happy insurrection oh man
[Music]
[Laughter]
what a good son yeah for her big 70th
birthday this year
nice sweet i am also here in the corner
i really enjoyed talking to tina before
the show and i'm delighted to get more
into it it reminded me a little bit of
talking to ricardo lamass's dad where we
get to get into some of the history and
get some of the background that we
really lack kind of as millennials so
i'm excited for tonight it's gonna be
good people are pointing out that
there's a blue tint on my camera there
is i'm sorry
it's on purpose oh you know i thought i
needed a little blue little red you know
uh if you haven't already before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
members because as members you keep our
journalists employed we're actually
looking at hiring two more journalists
to our news team so i'm really really
excited about that and uh your
membership is what gives these people
jobs so they work for you and that means
that whenever you see them you can yell
and be like hey i pay your salary you
know like you do with cops no i'm just
kidding but uh our journalists really do
rely on memberships our our website does
and as a member you get access to
exclusive segments from the tim cast irl
podcast we had lauren southern the other
day and uh for some reason every time
she comes she likes touching the swords
that are all over the place and she held
the meteorite sword terrifying and then
it was a really goofy episode we talked
about
pizza places in the middle of the
outback but it was interesting and fun
so become a member help support our work
but don't forget to like this video
right now smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with all your friends tell them it's the
best show ever let's read this first
story and talk about weird whatever with
florida the daily mail reports florida's
governor ron desantis is applauded by
children as he officially strips disney
of its 55 year old special tax and land
privileges after biden slammed ugly gop
for going after mickey i kind of feel
like
this country is pretty much falling
apart
uh i will say
it's funny that they bring in a bunch of
kids they have a photo of this they had
a photo here we go look at this they
have like you know
crt is is in a circle with a line
through it is there a word for that
wouldn't have been crt no no no when
they put a circle with a line through it
crossing something out or whatever but
they brought a bunch of kids and they're
all clapping and cheering i think that's
i think that's funny i like what he's
doing though i like what uh what ronna
sanchez is doing and we can see that
disney continues to drop in its stock
prices so i'll just i'll just start off
by saying this i went to there's a
protest in disneyland that i went to oh
no no that was disney world
that's the one in florida disney world's
in florida world yeah the other one's
anaheim okay so i was at disneyland uh
there was a protest for black lives
matter
i i don't think it was necessarily black
lives matter but it was the same issues
and the police did everything in their
power to protect disney and they were on
horseback with boken you know boken are
a wooden sword yeah wooden swords and it
was like the weirdest thing but what
people noticed was that they weren't
protecting any of the homes they were
protecting they were blocking off the
roads to disney and these were guys who
were like wearing full like camo decked
out military gear riding on the side of
suvs with with long guns is just the
craziest thing
isn't it weird though how the democrats
are now like like on the side of the big
corporate entity disney so yes it is are
they or are they just against desantis i
can't get a read on this no they're
they're they they're an amorphous blob
there's no i don't i don't they're not
for against anything they're just they
just hate you
right so it's like geez guys take it
easy well no but they do i mean if if
there's something that
i don't know civil libertarians and
conservatives are interested in they're
just going to be like well we hate that
and so if that means they're going to
side with tax cuts for massive
multinational corporations apparently
that's what's happening well but uh you
know this is why i think it's it's great
to have you here tina i'm curious with
everything we've been seeing uh over the
past several years with the rioting with
the political partisanship with now
children clapping and cheering for this
stuff with with critical race theory in
schools i'm wondering if you have ever
seen it this bad no i mean i haven't
we were talking earlier about
my sort of coming of age which was i was
in
college in 1969 as a freshman in
washington
at georgetown and it was you know the
height of the vietnam war it was
civil rights it was women's rights
and
i don't know if i was more naive but i
was certainly way more clear about my
world than i am now and i'm 70.
shouldn't i be more clear about my world
now
with age and
theoretically wisdom
um
i don't know what that means
uh but do you mean by clear like you
don't know what's going on i don't know
where i don't know how to think about a
lot of things
anymore because i don't i i'm very
mistrustful of pretty much everything i
hear
and
we were talking earlier about just about
newscasters in my
day and you know it was walter cronkite
and um
chet huntley and david brinkley and
edward r murrow and you respected those
men and you didn't really know much
about them
except
the pitch of their voice when you knew
when something was serious you know if
i'm sure you've all seen the clip of
walter cronkite taking his glasses off
when he announced jfk
had been assassinated it was a i don't
know things were it's almost like
things were serious then
and
everything's made to be serious now
yeah i don't know if that's the right
way to put it but yeah
um
i i don't know if things are better or
worse we were talking lydia and i
earlier about our my mother saying you
know the world has always been bad
yeah so
i wonder though like how do you how do
you know you can trust those men like
walter cronkite then yeah they smoked
cigarettes well you didn't yeah exactly
so did my father do it yeah
um
you didn't think about it
there wasn't a question of trust it was
there were three networks
there were very many fewer platforms for
information
and you didn't hear about as many things
at the same time
and it was i don't know
it was just easier possible they were
lying
well that's that's also possible gulf of
tonkin yeah gulf of tonkin exactly well
there was a lot of that i mean bay of
pig the cia
there was always a
subterranean text that
you'd well you didn't question it i
think is also
we also talked about in the past how at
that time the young people were part of
the counter culture which was counter
culture
and now you know with a lot of the
protests that happened over the last two
years you have like corporations on
board with those and like using it to
prove that they're virtuous oh i i i
went to a skate park
and i saw black lives matter tagged
and then i just started laughing and
they're like kids hanging out and i was
like which one of you kids tagged the
corporate slogan on the on the
skateboard
okay it's but they don't care you know
they're gonna they're gonna look at me
and they're like you're an old man you
don't get it and i'll be like yeah when
i was your age we we rebelled against
authority you know we tried to find our
own way but you guys are just stooges
they're just like well walmart told me
to write it so i did it's like all right
good for you i guess what strikes me is
the watergate scandal when that popped i
mean that was like the end of nixon's
his campaign at the time i believe and
correct me if i'm wrong what i mean he
he was didn't you didn't he he resigned
or that was the end of his presidency he
resigned he resigned yeah before because
he was spying on the democrats during
that campaign and then when they found
out when hillary's emails popped and
they just spying on bernie's campaign is
that right she was spying they were
supposed to be trump on trump's campaign
yeah uh where's the outrage where is the
water sandbag bernie's um yeah yeah they
were planning on talking about him being
jewish and using it against him and
stuff in the emails like how is this not
causing a watergate level landslide of
of reprisal
because there's a military-industrial
complex and now the the spy network it's
like they've been trying to build this
technocracy since 1913 the rockefeller
you know the military industry the uh
basically the federal reserve was the
first the beginning of it with
uh what's his name
uh woodrow wilson and now they have the
technology in place to actually spy with
the patriot act and things like that and
so they're like just they don't even
care anymore they're just trying to take
control of everything it's so gross have
you been following the critical race
theory stuff in the news
as much as i
as much as it has sustained my interest
which is not
none
well i shouldn't put it that way um
no comment
you know because i don't know if you
wanted to talk about the comparison
between feminism then and feminism today
well
i wouldn't feminism and critical race
theory
critical theory right yeah so so what
we're seeing now uh started with what's
called intersectional feminism
which is a tenet of critical race theory
so
it starts with second wave feminism
which i believe is what like the 60s 70s
first wave was like suffragettes
third wave i think was what was what we
saw in the 2000s
and now
so this is all just considered to be
waves of feminism
so what happens is
third wave feminism started asking these
questions about privilege
intersectionality and race
and so what started very much with
if you're a woman a biological female
then you know you have certain rights
and things you're not granted access to
so those rights are you know hard are
fought for and uh it's like workplace
pay you know pay parity things like that
and then you get into the late 2000s
early 2010s and feminism all of a sudden
starts adopting what's called
intersectionality which is what is i
don't know i don't know what that is
what is intersectionality
intersectionality is that sorry
a woman faces a certain kind of
discrimination
so do what everybody does and so
intersectionality says the
discrimination faced by a woman is
different than the discrimination faced
by a black woman why because at the
intersection of race and feminism there
is something unique
that is experienced only by black women
so specifically there is the trope of
the angry black woman
so when someone is being sexist towards
a black woman there's an element of race
comprised within it
okay from there
which is so so intersectional is
intersectionality is a component of
critical race theory okay it's way too
i look at it a lot more simply i think
you know certain if you want to talk
about women
certain women have it harder than other
women and i think probably black women
do generally you know across the board
women who are poor women who are raising
children by themselves
you know women
it some people have it easier some women
have it easier than other women i can't
i can't relate to
i don't get it the intersectionality
hole i don't know it's a way of talking
about it in a complicated in a
complicated it's a way of making sense
of the world and you know it's like a
way of
basically identifying
the reasons for
why people face struggles and why you
know
certain people have to overcome more but
at the same time like just those
exterior immutable traits
really don't have anything to do with
people's individual situations um in
terms of like
what they might be born into that's
beyond that you know it puts you in a
box effectively the result is that these
schools are now telling white kids that
they're inherently bad right
you know and they're saying white white
white is bad and whiteness is evil and
so now you have kids who are coming home
and telling their parents their parents
are revolting and now you're getting
republicans winning in a bunch of
different states so it seems like
you know you see bill maher wake up to
this kind of stuff he starts talking
about how the democrats are basically
destroying themselves by isolating and
and
fracturing their their their voting
blocks well isn't this also it's kind of
an extension of um
erasing
culture in a way i mean it's all sort of
the same it's
trying to make a new reality out of
something that was not
a pleasant reality is that
reinterpreting our past yeah like this
is a really simple way to put it i i
don't watch the news a lot anymore
and i watch tmc or tcm it's the movie
channel
and it's really well done it's all the
old movies it's the movies i grew up
with that my mother you know knew all
the word songs
to the word the words to all the songs
to
and they have adapted this position of
you know there's this whole conversation
about say gone with the wind as an
example
and
just erasing it because it represented
um
a bad thing about you know whites and
slavery
but there's no point in erasing
any of it let's face what it was and
move on and is that isn't it a similar
kind of
conversation well now uh
you know california just tried repealing
their civil rights provision from their
constitution
the the the democrats in california
wanted to repeal
the
anti-discrimination provision which
prevented discrimination the basis of
race
and their argument was we need to
discriminate on the basis of race to
help minorities
and and so you know my response there is
like to to go back in time yeah to you
know the pre-1960s
as some as some like you think it was
better when that's how the laws were
structured but that's what they're doing
that's the democrats that are doing that
it's not the republicans and then it's a
question of how far you go back in time
because oh you know um
if you go back on a long enough timeline
like for example the irish were being
enslaved by the hundreds of thousands
per year in baghdad in the 800s and at
that time the arabs were the dominant
culture in the world the irish yeah the
irish were getting dragged over to
basically slave markets all over the
world by the vikings and stuff like that
they just come in grab them and you know
and the british are in baghdad
yeah and the slavs which is where slave
comes from and the italians
the vikings would go down the rhine they
sacked paris they were everywhere they
were in the mediterranean that was nuts
now look at norway and they built
castles in sweden and they couldn't
penetrate the castles that's crazy
though right because when you look at
the the nordic countries they're very
effeminate
anymore yeah so a lot of people are
wondering like wow this they used to be
particularly barbaric you know seriously
going around stealing people
and now they're all very much like
equality and you know fair wages it's
like all right well and that's yeah
that's the other problem with applying
like immutable you know characteristics
to cultures and stuff like that like oh
because you're born like this then
you're
because you're like this you're going to
face this challenge you know because
yeah actually i think if you look at the
nordic countries it's a really good
example for why we should not blame a
group of people for the sins of their
past yeah to say like you know right now
that's the big thing with critical race
theory is that white people are evil
settler colonialism is wrong and english
is an oppressive language and it's like
i don't know if the uh
you know the vikings can figure things
out and become
you know i don't know what equitable and
peaceful or whatever why are you gonna
blame them for what other people did
right
that's true and i mean
that's really the question is like what
is um you know america is a very like
young country and i think that a lot of
times our collective understanding of
culture and history is
very much shorter than like in europe
for example like if you next to your
school you have a cathedral from the
1200s you have a tendency to like think
of things on a longer timeline and so
yeah we have this very kind of like it's
our understanding of like the history of
progressivism is like three generations
long and you know it's like
i think that that neglects to realize if
you think back a little bit further then
you realized more progress than you
think has been made you're making me
think about second wave feminism which
is the one from the 60s the first wave
feminism was the end of the 1800s it was
like the right what is it suffrage yeah
suffrage um so what is your
definition of feminism as you knew it
growing up
well i i guess i fall into the second
wave i i never really got it straight
but um
it's just
being a woman and being
proud of being a woman and not
having to
defend yourself because you are whether
or not you decide to have children you
have five children you work you don't
work
i think that we've kind of been led
astray
the women after me i think
um
had
got kind of mixed up with it because
what my generation was trying to do i
think was say whatever it is oops yeah
you need to keep it a little closer oh
sorry
you can move it around whenever you move
i don't know it just boils down to
having the courage to
be who you are i mean basically if and
if if you're a woman it's more
complicated because you have a womb well
hold on what what is a woman
what
nominated the supreme court and
confirmed said she could not answer the
question of what is a woman
because she's not a biologist so so my
question to you is second wave feminist
well i mean it this is all way beyond me
i'm just i i grew up
as a woman
because i have a womb
and i have an ability to bear children
this is as far as i'm going to go with
it right now
and i made a choice
i always wanted to have children i don't
know if that was cultural or if it was
hormonal or whatever but um it was very
important to me
and i never felt as though that was
challenged in terms of i was lucky you
know i never felt like
i had to fight for that
and at the same time i wanted
i wanted to be out there in the world
and work
and
it made economic sense and it just made
sense in terms of whatever my ambitions
were
and i was very fortunate because i had
the resources to
[Music]
work and
have my children
and it's mostly because i had very
understanding
employers who happened to be mostly men
who were liberated you know who allowed
me to
have my children keep my job and carry
on and
i don't know what happened i think
women started wanting this is not a
gender conversation for me
it's more about and i you know
you've got that
it's hard for me to to talk about it in
terms other than
um
being
someone who bears children and works and
just you know fends for
whatever it is is important to
me in the world i think wom the letters
womb and woman i mean the wom is part of
both of those words i don't know if that
matters but i'm not going to say it
doesn't and i'm not going to i can't
criticize again yeah but i can't
criticize someone who
you know has
has a struggle with
figuring out
what gender they are
i i don't have a problem with it i'm
lucky you know i guess or i'm i'm
i wasn't never taught to challenge it so
i'm
with
our incoming supreme court justice who
doesn't know what a woman is how can how
can you have feminism how can you have
women's rights if a supreme court
justice doesn't even know what a woman
is or can't define it
i mean it feels to me like feminism is
out the window i don't i don't think
that's true i think feminism is
more about the in
i don't think it it one supreme court
judge is going to affect
a culture
in terms of well it's the other way
around the judge is saying she can't
define women because the culture has
already changed i know what i'm saying
is that won't necessarily alter
uh the majority of women's
struggles
one way or the other necessarily i agree
i just think that it will amplify will
make them worse
i don't know about i don't know well so
for instance california tried repealing
the civil
non-discrimination provision from their
constitution if that were to be removed
then an employer it was it was public
contract and they could literally say
you're a woman get out
so that sounds like going backwards from
civil rights the 1964 civil rights act
granted those protections california
enacted a similar provision in schooling
and public contracting in the 90s and
the democrats are trying to be rid of
that so all of a sudden you know the
argument from democrats and these
progressives is that if we have the
ability to discriminate we can actually
discriminate against men and and that's
literally their argument so we can help
women by removing men but that just
means that a man could do the same thing
in kind and you'd come back to the point
where the people who are more aggressive
and more ambitious ambitious will
dominate the industry and then if they
have the ability to discriminate you
have a tendency to see it at least to a
certain degree i think that makes
struggle for even worse i mean it gets
even more interesting like if you're
talking about the case of california and
removing those uh civil rights
protections is
right now in like
i'm 32 like our age group and lower uh
women actually in academ like academic
scenarios and early work environments
are more successful than men so you know
if more women are enrolling in college
and getting better grades then in that
case they would actually be right at a
disadvantage for you know getting uh the
you know having the uh
whatever the i think intersectional i i
think the whole thing is just
it absolutely destroys women so what
what's happening now with it's going to
take way more than that to destroy women
tim well i i i i certainly don't i'm not
saying all women will be destroyed i'm
saying the rights gained over the past
several decades so what's going to
happen now there are more women in
college they're going to be laden with
more debt young men aren't taking these
are less likely to take out this debt
and they're going to be more well
they're going to be less restricted
they're going to be able to go into
trade jobs which will make
maybe not as money but with no debt
they're going to be unrestrained
so it really feels like everything
that's happening yeah but don't you
think there's it's a pendulum just
the way historically everything has been
for hundreds and hundreds of years you
know you go too far and then you come
back it's just a natural it's kind of a
spiral it goes to the left and then it
goes to the right and then it goes to
the left but it's always moving forward
i'm looking at these waves of feminist
golden ratio yeah the first one happened
in the late 1800s it was 60 years later
that you got the second wave then
it was 28 years later that you got the
third wave then it was like 15 years
later you got the fourth wave now
they're talking about eight years later
you're starting to see maybe there's a
fifth wave i mean you know women who who
thought who wanted to behave like men in
the workplace i think set set feminism
back yeah
you know
i think women were
more of a problem for women at certain
points than men were for women
and so it's it's never one you know it's
a dynamic i think it doesn't there isn't
one
thing that will determine forever the
way things will continue to be i don't
think i mean
hopefully the constitution you know and
the things that um
established our country will remain and
not not you know i i believe already
what
no yeah
like the right to keep and bear arms we
endlessly talk about this it's com it's
gone i mean sure you can try and go
we're in maryland right now you go you
go to maryland and say i would like a
gun they say no get out i mean the
constitution does not protect our rights
so you want to talk about free speech
but when private corporations control
the public town square i guess
technically you can go outside and talk
but now they've even arrested people for
posting rap lyrics if if i have to go to
the government and ask permission to get
to keep and bear arms the constitution
has not protected my rights and that's
true for new york new jersey maryland
what other states we have california
hawaii uh dc is not a state but yes
absolutely
you can't have you can't have a gun so
what constitution and then we talk about
the fifth amendment i mean look at the
stuff they do to julian assange he's not
an american citizen but certainly when
it comes to matters of you know
extradition or whatever people coming to
this country are that you are afford
rights no matter whether or not you're a
citizen but you look at what's happening
with january 6. the the defendants who
are kept in solitary confinement for a
year there's no constitutional rights
it's it's rights for those who have
power and the constitution's become a
piece of paper that's only being upheld
by one side that desperately wants to
believe it still exists do you think
it's because we've been like lulled into
a
like a comfortable place where we don't
realize how important like you know
carving those things out is like
you know everything's so safe and easy
right now that it's like okay well maybe
um you know the government can go ahead
and do whatever they want it's it's it's
cultural enforcement it's what a society
is willing to tolerate so if
you know the the feds stormed some women
in alaska's house because they thought
she she went into the capital building
on january 6.
where's the protests where's where is
the anti-government where's the
anti-authoritarian protest for that
stuff they don't care we had the the
worst riots we've seen in 50 years in
2020 and it was by
the people claiming to be the left the
left is now pro-corporate when they want
to be there's like there's no principles
backing this
the right tries to maintain this this
idea that there's a constitution and
that we have rights and these things are
being upheld but when every major
institution is corrupt you just got a
group of conservatives who are like
there's a constitution as long as it
stands and it's like bro you live in the
past
like hollywood schools like the crt and
school stuff is a perfect example
absolute corruption the media then lies
to cover up the extreme stuff they're
pulling off let me actually let me let
me pull up this story right here
florida shares examples of critical race
theory in banned textbooks what me
racist more than two million people have
tested their racial prejudice reads one
textbook's math problem so florida got
rid of a bunch of math books because
they said they had racial critical race
theory indoctrination in them
now
prominent progressives and leftists are
saying the right is banning math because
they don't want people to learn math
what you actually see in these books is
it says things like
the bar graph shows the dip the
differences among age groups on the
implicit association test that measure
measures levels of racial prejudice
higher scores indicate a stronger bias
what does that have to do with math why
are they showing these graphs adding and
subtracting polynomials what me racist
more than 2 million people have tested
their racial prejudice online using a
version of the implicit
association test many groups average
scores fall between slight and moderate
bias
that's in a math book when they when
they when they remove those books from
school democrats corporate press and
progressive activists make up insane
lies yeah but everybody i mean it's all
propaganda you have propaganda on both
sides and i mean this is a math book
though this is like a grade school math
book
okay where is that book is it all over
america is it in all the schools now
florida state the textbooks have gotten
pretty clear
okay so florida is one of 50 states okay
i think you know this is happening all
over the place like virginia for example
okay but but there's a little bit of
broad sweeping generalization here i
mean i have more
faith in
in our
world than
believing that all this stuff is going
to stick some of it's going to buff out
tim
well yeah because
people have started to stand up and say
no yeah but it seems like it's it's it's
mostly uh only in florida right so so
disney comes out and
what's happening in florida if you're
not familiar is they passed a bill
called the parental rights and education
bill which
grants parents the right to know i know
now what happens immediately is don't
say gay but the bill nowhere in any way
has anything to do with that right the
bill is just you know certain sex had
concepts for you know for kindergarten
to third grade not allowed and the
teachers can't keep secrets from the
parents on physical mental or medical
issues parents have a right to know
what's in their curriculum
the media comes out and says don't say
gay that's not true the only people
fighting back against this are for the
most part in florida we did see after
this i think tex texas idaho mississippi
we're starting to see statewide
hyperpolarization to push back but it's
it's really polarizing so a better
example is probably abortion where
oklahoma i think outright banned
abortion just literally banned it unless
it's for the life of the mother and
colorado now allows abortion up to the
point of birth meaning a fully developed
nine-month-old baby can be two extremes
yeah right yeah and and so this is
what's happening in in this country so
it's not that it's buffing out it's that
the the lines that there's two distinct
cultures that have emerged i know but
that for right now and this is what
happens historically and
everything doesn't everything is it's
not everything moves you know it doesn't
stay in the same place and
having
conversations and arguments and
providing a forum for
uh debate is what we have to keep going
so the
the the left as i guess it would be
colloquially described won't come on a
show like this
that's why i came on the show who is the
left so uh typical typically uh there is
left is a reference to tribal spheres of
influence as is right it doesn't really
mean much of anything i just mean who
are like who have you asked well no we
can't get into that i i
well so there's a lot of people
it's funny you say that because recently
there have been a couple of invitations
right absolutely so one of the most
notable is one of the biggest political
streamers for the left is hassan [ __ ]
who i've repeatedly invited on the show
but he's always got a different excuse
the first time it was you know i said i
tweeted out we we invite these people on
the show they always say yes and then
ghost us
and then hassan tweets out i'll come on
your show i said we will pay for
everything we'll get you a hotel we'll
bring you out in style then he privately
messages me saying nah i'm scared of
cove and i won't do it.
now he's saying i'm i'm not gonna travel
to your show i'm too busy
we recently had another guy that i was a
uh
that was arguing and posting outright
lies
and it's just insane that these people
i'll tell you i'll tell you how crazy it
is
i'm holding up a pen you can see it yeah
i'm not holding a pen
that's what they do the washington post
published the private address of someone
on twitter you can see it and they're
going no they didn't and you're like why
am i even talking to you if you're just
going to say something so you just have
to find other people
there's no other people there have to be
other people have you been did you watch
the um
the french you know uh macron and uh le
pen okay now they were given this is
this is the way we should debate things
they're each given like i don't know
what it is like an hour and a half
and there's no like you know you have 30
seconds to answer this question and they
actually they insult each other they
talk to each other but they have enough
time
to actually have a conversation so this
is which is a debate which is instead of
a sound bite here and there yeah so we
that's why we have this you know two and
a half hour long show
now uh shout out to vosh he's a he's a
leftist socialist a youtuber who a lot
of people on the right hate especially
because of his his views on children and
adult content for children
but he came on the show twice
and uh that's that's that's pretty much
there's also jen pearlman shout out to
jen she's a progressive and she's come
on the show we've had great
conversations but this this this guy who
was recently arguing that something that
literally happened didn't message me
saying he'll come on the show i say here
email us so we can set it up and then he
goes to us it's just it's a recurring
well that's cowardly i think what it is
is like you're so
we talked earlier before the show about
like are we inheriting you know the tail
end of the
uh counterculture progressive movement
that you guys initiated in the late 60s
and like i think to a certain extent
what we're talking about here when you
say what is the left i mean to a certain
extent it has become orthodoxy of this
kind of like monolithic you know
mainstream idea of what it is to be a
good person to be a moral virtuous
person and so
anybody who engages with a tim pool is
stepping outside of that orthodoxy and
and nobody wants to be
that person who you know steps outside
of where everybody is you know thinking
right and doing it but i did and a lot
of my old friends won't talk to me or
don't talk to me they unfollow me and
stuff because it's like ian's a part of
the fascist movement of the united
states where i'm like yo the federal
reserve shout out to everyone in the
chat that loves that one is fascist i'm
trying to expose that stuff
and
uh
like the establishment i guess we call
it the establishment they just outright
make things up right i think that left
and right is a communist i mean it goes
back to the french revolution where
people sat on the left they were the
revolutionaries people sat on the right
they were the loyalists and so it really
literally comes from they call
themselves the left and the right of the
aisle
mao talked a lot about the rightists and
he persecuted the rightists in the
cultural revolution of china and so i
think that somehow they've wormed that
into our modern discourse to get us to
divide each other
i look at uh
we just had the mask singer do you guys
see this
uh rudy giuliani turned out to have been
the mask singer and who was the guy
yeah there's that show the mountain
there's a show called mask singer where
someone wears a costume and sings okay
and then they got to guess who it was
weird show turns out the mask comes off
rudy giuliani he's got a beautiful voice
turns out well so uh i think it was ken
jong was that his name
oh yeah he walks off stage
i thought about that because people have
said that twitter isn't real life for a
long time that social media isn't real
life i think the real issue is that
twitter has always been real life but
for a younger generation what i see
happening now is when you look at cable
tv cnn msnbc and fox news their viewers
are overwhelmingly over 56 years old
so
all of this stuff is happening
it is it is worse than i've ever seen it
granted i'm only 36
and i feel like the old generation
doesn't understand how bad it is because
they're not actually in the same culture
as the rest of them that's possible
that's quite possible
so for you know richie to experience
things on the ground
i'll give you
one of my favorite examples of the the
hyper polarization is a man named daryl
davis
he's a he's an old black jazz musician
he thought to himself one day how could
someone hate me if they never met me so
he went to a clan rally met some old
clansmen started talking to him and he
said sure enough they were racist but
after a few weeks to a few months these
guys started taking off their robes and
saying i was completely wrong they're
like the things they say about black
people does not represent my good friend
daryl he told one story about how he met
this klansman who was high ranking and
he had his he he was just he would have
had this dream to see this famous rock
and roll car in a museum or something
like that and daryl's like oh i can get
you in there and he was like get out of
here. and then here he is this racist
guy having his dream come true granted
to him by by a black man and these
people were like all of a sudden like
this racist stuff is wrong
so this is daryl davis we booked him uh
he's incredible i'm a huge fan how old
is he
uh you can't find out i'm not sure he's
going to be here actually uh
and we booked him for an event to
headline because the event was about
essentially civil libertarianism it was
called ending violence racism and
authoritarianism we wanted people to be
like we want to get rid of this stuff
far left extremists showed up and
threatened to burn down the theater so
the theater canceled our contract within
i think it was like three weeks of the
event we were forced to move the event
to a casino with half the capacity
because the casino had the security and
they were willing to do it another venue
nearby told us we love what you're doing
but we will have our venue burn down if
we host this conversation
the protesters showed up to the after
party and daryl davis
having de-radicalized over 200 klansmen
said i'm gonna go talk to these guys and
see what's up and yet they did they
screamed at him and wouldn't let him say
one word he was so shocked he wrote he
wrote this this post on facebook where
he said i i can't believe it i've never
experienced anything like this
what is what is going on with these
people and ended up going massively
viral because the current state of
politics in this country is the younger
left generation we call it the left
whatever we call it group a group b
whatever
they are unwilling to compromise
unwilling to talk they are uh angry
chaotic and destructive
so uh for example the guy who said the
washington post never posted a private
address and everyone's showing the image
of them doing it and he's like no they
didn't
these are people who don't care about
what's true they know that they can say
it and their people gullible enough to
just believe it and that gives them
power
so you have uh it was the late david
graber who said
elements of the left have adopted the
fascistic tenet there is no truth but
power and uh this guy was called the
anarchist anthropologist he was one of
the progenitors of occupy wall street
he uh later in his life he said i'm
watching the left embrace fascistic
tenets
and that's and that's where we are now
where
uh the corporate press will outright
make something up their allies and
non-profits will make things up the
whole insurrection narrative all of this
stuff are outright lies my favorite
example in this capacity is that in
january i said it's going to be very
difficult to convict someone of
trespassing at the capitol when the
police opened the doors for them the
young turks then make up a lie that i
said people who are violent shouldn't be
charged because there were no signs
right and it works for their audience i
invite them on the show i say we'll
cover all your costs we've known each
other for years they laugh and they say
of course not we don't care we don't
actually care about this stuff
daryl davis is 64 years old by the way
she's turned 64 in march happy birthday
i think that's a that's a good point
though tim it's like that's it's like a
lack of any initiative to engage with
the other side and i'm wondering like
back in the 60s and 70s like
you know somebody who was like a bible
thumping you know whatever world war ii
veteran who had the white picket fence
and then their kid went off to vietnam
and they were all for you know were you
not not willing to engage with somebody
like that like was it you know if you're
this then i won't even talk to you i
think
you know when
earlier we talked about it being more
generational
than partisan
um because we were filled with hope
about the fact that we could make a
change we could make a difference we
could end the war
and
if it might have been naive but that's
how we united
and we disagreed i mean richard nixon
was the enemy
because he perpetuated the war
and uh but would you talk to a nixon
supporter like because i think that's i
tried to talk to my father about it well
the the feminists today are pro-war
what do you that's a broad
generalization but it's true what do you
mean i'm a feminist i'm not pro-war
right so my generation's feminists are
pro-war
but we've got
i didn't say absolutely i'm saying if
you were to take 10 modern feminists
right now and ask them if they wanted
intervention in ukraine they'd say yes
that's probably fair point absolutely
donald trump uh got us the abraham
accords i'm so confused about everything
there's like second third way of
feminism from 1994 there's fourth wave
feminism from 2010 so you got to be
specific well i'll put it this way i'll
put it this way either tacitly or or
directly pro war uh for our generations
feminists right the people who would
wear those pink hats right now are the
ones with the ukraine flags and their
bios and they're and they're the ones
that i don't think that's absolutely
true mine
were one of those uh pink hats right so
i'm not saying absolutely i'm saying you
know she didn't why if you take ten of
these people and ask them do you think
the us should be involved in the ukraine
russia war they'll say yes
i think chris chris coons the democratic
senator said it's time for us boots on
the ground yeah i mean it's a paradigm
shift it's a paradigm shift right there
are still plenty of those hippies but
granola folks those are the they're also
like anti-facts a lot but
but take a look at this point uh with
donald trump no new wars
for the first time in my life a
president did not start a war in fact
with uh with kushner's guidance we got
the abraham accords which brought
economic stability between countries
like uh saudi arabia or the or uh or
just countries
with israel so now planes are allowed to
fly over israel tremendous peace there
was also i think
what else was it was it bosnia he had
that uh other peace agreement he was
withdrawing our troops from afghanistan
he was getting our troops out of syria
he was uh
generally
making moves to end war and that's one
of the reasons i did not vote for him in
2016 but i did in 2020 because he's had
a timeline for the withdrawal from
afghanistan but
today's feminists of my generation
oppose that
and they voted for joe biden
who was part of an administration that
caused i think seven wars started seven
wars
so whether tacitly or directly and
testedly i say
you look at donald trump's body of work
as an activist and you say
i'd rather vote for the guy who starts
war as opposed to the guy who ends them
they're pro-war that's tacit now the
direct stuff is the people who right now
are aligning with democrats saying they
want intervention in ukraine malcolm
nance i mean he's an msnbc host went to
to ukraine he's 60 years old and he's
got a big picture of himself holding a
gun and tactical gear these people are
outright pro-war well i think that they
think if we go in we'll end the war
which is why that's probably more
involved it's not a united states uh
issue yeah but neither was world war ii
talking about the real threat we're
talking about paris it's a regional
conflict so was world war ii if vladimir
putin invades poland nato can intervene
ukraine is not not a nato country it is
not an eu country and they have a con
conflict with russia and you have
democrats and the the you know our
generations left saying intervention war
weapons etc i mean it's absolutely
insane that the arguments i'm hearing
from progressives are that we should
have a no-fly zone which is a
declaration of war on russia yeah i
think they're misguided but a lot of
them are it's like it's almost as if i
mean that is kind of embedded in exactly
what you said is kind of
the substance of a paradigm shift which
is like it used to be the right that was
always reactionary and always responding
from what the left did and you know
whatever they do we have to oppose
because we need to retain our traditions
and values but now it's like
it's almost like once donald trump took
control of the republican party it's
like every the left has to react to
everything that they do and say no
that's got to be but it was trump and
bernie yeah trump and bernie were a
generational
flip that just shocked the whole system
now bernie lost uh and you know hillary
won that primary donald trump stormed
his way into the republican party and
brought with him a wave of
you know
very much a shift from the traditional
conservative
model to a more left economic what about
north korea and the fact that he was
palsy whales he was that's fantastic i
nearly cried when um when he was
negotiating peace my my great
grandfather is from what would now be
called north korea and the prospect of
de-escalation was was was fascinating
and trump was negotiating that donald
trump crossed into north korean
territory with no security
that was one of the most profound
plus like anti-war moments of my life
we've been palsy wealthy with the saudi
arabians for generations and nobody's
called that into question because it's
not one of those but just just think
about this donald trump
crossed into north korea with no
security and walked peacefully up with
kim jong-un and i was just my jaw hit
the floor i was like they could have
snatched him up they could have grabbed
him and said now you give us what we
want they shook his hand he walked back
they smiled and waved and he left and i
said that is leadership donald trump
risked his life now i get it the threat
is backed by we have nuclear bombs but
we are not going to mutually assure
destruction they always say no donald
trump i couldn't believe he did that the
the guy they claim is the most selfish
and insane guy in the world just risked
his life for what point i was just like
it would it would be a profound moment
for me to hear that the korean peninsula
had been reunited and donald trump made
tremendous steps in that direction i i
don't think it was perfect i think kim
jong-un is a bad guy i think they they
took advantage of trump in many ways but
that was incredible
i'm looking at uh just as clarification
it looks like bosnia wasn't involved in
the peace deal but it was it was uh
serbia and kosovo oh sorry
yeah these peace deals yeah i do have a
lot of issues with trump he wasn't
definitely wasn't perfect but it's nice
to to see somebody that's not part of
the war machine but look at the people
who came out and were like oh the obama
administration the ones who signed the
indefinite detention provisions in the
in the national defense authorization
act barack obama who authorized
extrajudicial assassinations of american
citizens and they were like i would
rather have that guy his vice president
than donald trump who signed peace
agreements
and and and fo and worked towards ending
conflict internationally no new wars and
they voted for joe biden i just the left
is is profoundly pro-war when do you
think that happened was it like so you
just mentioned bosnia like ma during the
bosnia war the american public right
they were pretty for intervention right
like that was clinton
is that when it flipped when the left
wing started to become pro war
right because you were anti-war you were
progressive in the 60s
how did that change you know how like
why is it 2008
you think it was two george george w
bush i remember marching in protests
over the war in iraq and i was a
teenager so i knew very little for the
most part about what was going on other
than why are we invading this war over
weapons of mass destruction all that
stuff and we were told it wasn't true
people were marching with signs saying
george w bush was hitler and all that
and i was mostly just kind of like yeah
punk rock
screw the system george w bush is bad
and boy was it a cold splash of water
when we did it
barack obama got elected
and then i said all right well the first
thing obama did one of the first orders
he signed was bombing a village full of
women and children and i said guys guys
hey let's keep this protest going now
we're good and they all disappeared all
these anti-war protesters were gone
i think what happened was
it was this is the the emergence of
overt tribalism around the same time
facebook and twitter and these other
social networks that are emerging and
people developed tribal identities which
is i support barack obama that's who i
am i don't care what he does and for me
i was kind of like i think killing
children is bad so what was the what are
you referring to i'm not sure i remember
obama yeah barack obama authorized a
drone strike on a civilian restaurant in
yemen killing a 16 year old american
citizen named abdulrahman al-awlaki
and the response from the white house
when asked about it was
oops we were trying to kill a different
terrorist by bombing a civilian
restaurant just so turns out though
anwar al-awlaki his dad was an american
citizen who was also killed in an
extrajudicial assassination signed off
by obama and to me it sounded like obama
was sending a signal we will kill your
children that's just my opinion all that
matters is i won't speculate in the
absence of evidence the solution which
makes the least amount of assumptions
tends to be correct barack obama
authorized the assassination of an
american citizen by bombing a civilian
cafe and people voted for him again i
didn't and people voted for it as a vp
over donald trump i wrote a form twice
so here you have a guy who is quite
literally killing not only children in
these countries under the obama
administration in order to get around
the fact that it was being reported they
were executing civilians by drone they
said
if the male is over 18 we don't care
what they're doing carrying water
harvesting crops raising goats their
enemy combatants because their military
age
when our good friend luke redkowski
confronted the administration on the
execution of the american citizen
i can't remember the guy's name was
charlie gibbs he said he should have had
a better father that was their attitude
and so i sit here i watch all of this
stuff and then i say i have always
maintained that i think this is
disgusting since the george w bush era i
have learned my lesson with voting for
people like obama when donald trump came
around with hillary clinton i laughed
you think i'm voting for trump nice try
hillary clinton she's a warmonger to
beat out all war mongers she didn't get
my vote either and then in donald
trump's presidency we saw a return of
american manufacturing we saw a three
billion dollar investment in michigan we
saw a challenging of the racist policies
coming out of critical race theory and
we saw no new wars we saw historic peace
agreements and attempts at other
historic peace agreements and i said i
gotta vote for this guy he needs another
term and now what we have is the people
who are supposed to be anti-war are the
ones who are going around smashing
windows and starting fires cheering on
intervention and bombing in ukraine
calling for no-fly zones it's just
there was never in my life i think i was
taken for a ride early on when these
people claimed they were anti-war but
the whole time they were just i want
power and i will say whatever i have to
say to get it
obama did run on a platform of you know
non-intervention and pulling out of
middle eastern conflicts and
ultimately
it was quite the contrary you know was
it was it i think it was seven new wars
but i'm uh
yeah are you counting libya the no-fly
syria libya countries well i mean come
on hillary clinton we came we saw he
died yep so i'm still stuck on the
feminists being warmongers i still
haven't
cracked that
with respect to ukraine i i actually i
think that that's probably correct which
is the majority of you know progressives
yeah if you um bette midler she posted a
picture of like a a
three-year-old ukrainian girl waving a
flag and she's like we have to do it for
her you know it's like be you know be
brave or whatever just seeing the call
like uh i think it was chris coons he
said uh we need u.s soldiers on the
ground these are democrats the
republicans i think would love the war
the problem is the younger
civil libertarian types and
conservatives do not want war and that's
why they really like trump
so the republican party is is in a bind
you know they despise trump they despise
the populists but
so long as there are uh you know the the
left likes to you know the the democrat
aligned people like to call me right
wing and i'm like i don't care what you
call me i will vote for a republican in
two seconds if they if they stand by
ending foreign conflict but more more
incursions right i understand that if um
you know they're a terrorist right we
had 911. and tulsi gabbard i believe and
uh ron paul were both this is left and
right both of the opinion that
we should go after only terrorists not
declare war on entire nation and
destabilize their government and
nation-build ron paul said we should uh
enact a letter of mark and reprisal to
target those groups which is sending
private groups
to engage in low-tier
non-nation-wide conflict instead we were
like let's invade afghanistan tear down
their government and build up a new one
over 20 years never should have happened
so the democrats and the republicans
were totally on board with that you
bring me a donald trump and i laugh i
then watch him say here's the timeline
for our withdrawal from this country and
i was like okay go on he says i also
want to make sure we're not involved in
syria and i'm like yes what else he goes
abraham accords we're going to make
peace agreements in the middle east and
i was like all right this guy needs
another term instead the left the
progressives they said they made videos
saying trump is an existential threat to
america and we have to vote well he is
if you're a warmongering you know
international elite bankster supporting
warmonger whatever that's what we get so
the people who are like you know the the
feminists on youtube
uh the people who claim to be feminists
were the ones saying we should elect the
warmonger president with a corrupt son
who was doing illicit business dealings
in china and ukraine and i'm just like
these people have become just overtly
evil overtly not like uh trump's core
cult members are good people but donald
trump did such tremendous good i would
rather the united states have
internal problems than be blowing up
kids in foreign countries
well we definitely have internal
problems so you're winning on that one
no no no i'd rather it if it was one or
the other
you bring these problems here we can
work to solve them tim you've got to get
some left wingers in here well so uh
shout out shout out to matt bender who
is not emailed i don't like thinking a
left and right man
is the other unfortunately that's what
the conversation is it doesn't have to
be though well i agree but
like
they got us in a psychological war this
is intentional and it's been
instantiated so if you get angry you
lose we got to stay calm and direct and
focused and build things when we say
left or right
again it's it's literally just sphere of
influence signifiers like i said we can
call it group a group b
uh economically i'm center-left now they
don't care they say haha you know tim's
lying yeah but there have to be some
centrist
we had a couple we've had a couple
that's the problem
everybody's being it's it's
in the discourse within the discourse
well there's no nuance it's like you
either have to take this side or you
take that side you're pro ukraine or
you're pro-russia well here's the
question um do you believe it it is an
imperative
in subjects of politics and news to tell
the truth
yeah what is truth that's right-wing
the left believes there is no truth but
power
so there's a group called by any means
necessary they they will they will write
these things down they will tell you
that the ends justify the means so what
happens is why won't a leftist come on
this show a left winger
did joe biden engage in corrupt
activities with his son in ukraine the
answer is a fact it's yes we know this
through a series of court rulings
reporting and sworn affidavits from
people involved
the a prosecutor in ukraine was fired
because joe biden intervened and told
the president to fire him otherwise he
would illegally withhold us aid to
ukraine
the prosecutor was investigating a
company called barisma where joe biden's
son was on the board getting 83 000 a
month
these are facts now when i say that they
say you're conservative and i'm like i
didn't say anything about abortion or
taxes and that doesn't matter and if you
tell the truth they don't come on the
show because if they do
we can show them the facts and it's
forcing them with their audience in tow
to acknowledge that they were lying to
their audience
yeah but to continue talking us them
doesn't help anybody
well i was just going to say that you
know you said the left's consensus on
truth is
like truth is power i think it it really
did come out of like the counterculture
movement of the 60s and 70s and
post-world war ii europe where like
critical theory was this idea that
modernity and all the institutions that
have been built up around it were like
we need to re-examine this all of the
great works that prop you know propelled
western civilization forward
all of these ideas about science we need
to question all of it and so critical
theory is like you know the waves of
feminism that we're talking about are
successive waves of critiquing and
critiquing and at a certain point the
critique becomes the mainstream so like
that's where we're at now i suppose i
suppose my question is
why do you think it is you didn't know
that barack obama ordered the uh
a drone strike on a civilian restaurant
killing an american child i don't know
and i'm still listening with half an ear
you know i don't know
i think uh someone mentioned in the chat
and i you know i saw it that the issue
is people aren't
in the news
for for whatever reason they're either
not getting the information or they're
choosing to avoid the information i
certainly think cnn is just lying all
the time
and we constantly have to debunk a lot
of their lies
i would say
a good portion of cnn is is is actually
good reporting what about fox do you
think fox tells the truth all the time i
think fox is talking about truth
absolutely yeah fox's news reporting
just like cnn's tends to be actually
really good uh bret bayer and bill
hammer do a really great job tucker
carlson does a good job
uh sean hannity and laura ingram are
just particularly biased i'm not a big
fan
and tucker has had his goofy segments
where he's like eminems aren't sexy or
whatever uh rachel maddow however like
for years just
egged on insane conspiracy theories
about russia that we're just so over the
top and without basis
any any rational person should have
stopped from them and say is this lady
lying to me
the thing about truth and honesty is if
you believe something is real but it's
not and you tell someone it's real
you're wrong but you're not lying you
don't because you're not you're not
intentionally deceiving them so a lot of
people are just wrong because they
haven't done the research or they
haven't seen the research or it's been
obfuscated from them or all the above so
when
taylor lorenz of the washington post
puts a direct link
to the private home address
of an individual in her story
and then there's a backlash so the
washington post removes it and then
issues a public statement statement we
did not link to private details an
outright lie that is not wrong that is a
lie because they removed it which means
they knew it was there which means the
statement after the fact is a provable
lie
and and for whatever reason these these
democrat voter progressive activists
people like uh matt bender who never
emailed to come on the show agreed to
just pretend like it's true because
these people are
they they have the fat the the fascistic
tenant there is no truth but power and
that's me citing the anarchist
anthropologist the late david graber
so what am i supposed to do i don't know
that's what i'm trying to figure out
you've you've always followed like the
traditional news sources and we always
have conversations where it's like wait
what are you talking about like what is
this thing that's going on that's
apparently a problem that i haven't
heard about and it's because
you know kind of all of those corporate
institutions that tell people what's
going on in the world it behooves them
not to pay attention to those things
that are upsetting to what is done the
rules of the game have changed i mean
there aren't any rules anymore it seems
right and it's it seems like the only
people following the rules are what is
colloquially colloquially known as the
right but richard what did the new york
times say about you they called me a
writer that's right
and they knew it wasn't true right and
he punched well there's yes there's a
longer story there which we'll i'll
explain in um
as i'm writing it down
um but basically what happened was that
they took a photograph of me
i have a certain appearance
i look a little bit like a knuckle
dragon neanderthal
who would you know be like one of those
uh you know trump supporting monkeys and
so then they saw the photo of me after
being pepper sprayed and they
you know took that surface level
uh assumption but really if they had
have looked you know even for 10 minutes
they would have realized that they were
allowed on my reporting in kenosha so
um really what it was there is oh he's
you know he's a rioter he's a trump
supporter we don't even need to do our
due diligence because he's you know he
doesn't deserve and the photograph was
taken in front of that you know that
famous photo with the door punched right
that was shattered
and they said who punched the door yeah
so if they if they said it i mean can
you imagine my mom was so pissed she was
like who is give me that guys
that night and a good friend of mine
talked me out of it because it wouldn't
have done richie anything so so there's
something called the gel man amnesia
effect this refers to when you encounter
a news story that you know to be false
yeah but then assume the news in other
areas is telling the truth
so you know what they said about your
own son right now imagine what every
story is like why assume any of the
other stories are true
well again i i would prefer
not to use these sweeping
generalizations
tim but i you know i'm listening
i just would like to figure out a way
that
there can be a more productive
conversation i mean
i don't know that you know when i was
marching in washington
going to arlington cemetery with we
carried coffins and you know it was a
very dramatic
effort
i'm not sure how many how many people we
alienated and how many people we sort of
um
corralled
but
it there just doesn't seem to be any
meeting of the ways anymore well the
right certainly is trying
again colloquially whatever you want to
call it the the
we've certainly reached out to tons of
people and you have this meme ben
shapiro yeah or saying debate me debate
me because
ben shapiro has consistently tried to
have sit down conversations with people
on the left they won't do it in fact so
it's true for him as well you're saying
oh this is a known issue right when when
ben shapiro went on this show he was
sitting next to a trans woman and he
when he gave his opinions the trans
woman grabbed him and threatened to put
him in the hospital
ben shapiro still will invite people to
to come
debate him or he you know to be fair ben
told us he's like i don't ask for
debates i ask for conversations and if
we argue we argue they won't do it when
he tried showing up to depaul in chicago
the police told him if he took one more
step he would be arrested because it's a
safety risk these people have been
burning down buildings to prevent
conversations
we they threatened to burn down the
theater where we were hosting our event
because they wanted to stop and it
worked the the theater said sue me i
don't care the damages i'd have to pay
you are cheaper than me rebuilding my
theater so we had to move the event
because there's a certain level of
threat and pressure that normal people
cannot tolerate when when antifa is
allowed to kill
these black lives matter rioters and
antifa
their writing resulted in the death of
between 26 and 32 people
and kamala harris
donated she solicited donations on
twitter to bail these people out of jail
joe biden's staff members solicited
donations or actually gave donations to
bail these people out
when you have
the january 17th rioters i'm sorry the
january 20th writers in 2017 trump's
inauguration
they they torched a limo that belonged
to an immigrant they smashed a bunch of
windows and when the police arrested
them
they
they all got off in fact not only did
they get off they sued dc and won
millions of dollars
so now you have somebody who owns a
venue and they get a phone call and they
say we're antifa and you know what'll
happen they'll say anything you say
because the right isn't going to do this
the police also won't stop antifa but if
if a bunch of right wingers go go to the
capitol they'll get a year in solitary
confinement if you get 90 to 100 plus
days
of left-wing extremists fire-bombing a
federal building in the pacific
northwest
where
a handful of these people get charged
for sure but only the ones who really
pushed the boundaries for the most part
it's like anybody anybody who even
walked in the building you know
befuddled are getting called a violent
terrorist extremist and having their
jobs destroyed a woman who didn't even
go in had her home raided in alaska it's
very obvious that when you know bubba
wasn't in bubba wallace yeah has 12 fbi
gents or however many storm nascar over
a garage pole rope
but you can't get the fbi to investigate
you know very serious crimes like you
know
that we've seen with antifa then you
have to wonder uh i want to keep that
one a little vague but i've had my my
dealings were wondering like why isn't
uh you know with our security issues
where where's law enforcement like what
what was that there's there's an act
investigation maybe something will
happen but we've had death threats we've
had people call in fake swap police
raids to this building eight times and
the bomb squad has shown up it's
remarkable it's remarkable don't you
think the shoot like the shoe's kind of
on the other foot now though back in the
60s and 70s
it was all of these left-wing
progressive groups that were being
infiltrated by the authoritarian
government
it's not on the other foot it's i mean
well my point is is that now
it's the you know
that um
those groups aren't the ones that are
that are representing the same
existential threat that those people
were pro-free speech right and they were
anti-war which side is pro-free speech
and anti-war right now well that's yeah
so those who are for free speech the
rights of the people who are for pushing
back against corrupt corporate power and
war that would be described as today the
right
the left is
they're pro they're not protesting uh i
don't want to confuse that protest we
saw in the chamber because that was that
was debunked but there are people
outraged that
desantis stripped disney of their tax
privileges a massive multinational
corporation the left is like we should
give tax cuts these people should be
allowed ron desantis what he's doing is
wrong
it's just like why are you cheering for
the corporations they're they're they're
outraged that uh elon musk wants to buy
twitter saying oh no we can't let
billionaires get social media but
they've been defending these same
billionaires for a decade saying it's a
private company they can do what they
want
so
i i don't think i think left and right
are just
tribal signifiers we can call it up down
we can go left right we can call it a b
but it's not binary there's too many
there's so many different people with so
many different thoughts
if someone thinks that they're another
to you particularly for you if you're
like the left is horrible and that guy's
a leftist that guy's going to be like
well then dude i don't want to be near
you if you're going to call me that i'm
not ian i think you have an issue with
trying to dissect
for the sake of argument instead of
actually
engaging with the argument well i think
this is a part of the reason why you're
having trouble inviting certain people
on if you if you predispose them as
being part of this evil idea or group
then it's gonna be a lot harder to get
them to be like okay he's cool well you
are very passionate about it tim it's
true
so when
uh uh they post over like the young
turks right they just make things up
right
and i still
they literally do and then i don't
engage with them and how often do i say
call out people's names and and say them
infrequently maybe a couple times a week
or i usually say i don't want to say
their name yeah i don't want to minimize
harm when i privately reach out to them
they just say screw off
look man
i think there's a reality that you don't
want to acknowledge because for whatever
reason uh i don't know because you say
this all the time like oh we can't say
left or right yeah look because mao did
it you really want to be like mao you're
in the position of mao right now you
have that power that's a ridiculous
reduction you have a cultural revolution
of people that are listening to you
right now and and ian right see what
you're doing right now is you're
creating a false argument
no i'm this i'm very serious this
internet technology that guy did a thing
so if you do that thing it's the same
thing no you have that cultural power
that he had you have more power than he
had
i did not create the idea of leftists
existing
no no that was a french revolution thing
but but it's it's up to you man your
words are like
convincing people your issue is once
again semantics
definitely that's it or literally
whatever you want to call we should move
on i don't want to waste time arguing
the definitions of words that don't
actually add to the conversation i'm
saying if you if you divide people
then we're going to be living in a
divided society but if you unite people
then we will be united how do you unite
people by dispensing with these false
paradigms what dichotomy is the left and
right and b up and down people aren't
black and white
doesn't unr well we're in a paradigm
shift right so like some of our
definitions of things like left and
right republican and democrat are
changing and so i think a byproduct of
that is always going to be some degree
of uncomfortability where people are
like oh i'm outside of my comfort zone
this isn't exactly the way that i grew
up that i knew everything to be
so like on the one hand you're saying
oh we can't be using these terms because
it kind of casts people in these
whatever antiquated boxes
but also if you don't use words then how
can you communicate
you know any kind of ideas like about
these political
you know ideas like you have to put them
somewhere so like what would be your
solution there i think a lot of it is
communicating with emotions instead of
logic
how does that keep talking like like
you know you got to kind of understand
people and listen to them as they are
without labeling them
it's tempting to want to put people in
boxes so that you can understand them
maybe better but it's just about calming
people down really here i made a picture
nice there you go
magnetic field it's a butt crack no it's
uh
it's the left and the right
well turn it up turn it sideways now
what is it up and down yeah it doesn't
matter i'll rip it in half what is it
then it doesn't matter what you want to
call it the point is what i'm showing
you here is there's many different lines
and there's many different points and
they're all very far away from each
other but some of them
there's there's still a very clear split
between the two groups but you'll notice
in the middle they overlap a little bit
the point is using using terms like left
and right as i often say are
not absolute which you seem to think
they are
it's a description of the spheres of
influence that exist and have a slight
merger at the point where there's
some you know maybe what do they call it
the stressed side liners what pew
research called them
for the most part however everyone seems
to fall
on one side either by 0.1 degrees or by
100 degrees the fact remains left and
right are simply things we use to
describe the umbrellas that surround the
two different parent factions i thought
uh thomas massey came on the show a few
months ago and he was pretty said
something pretty profound where he said
in the back of like the chamber where
the congress hangs out there's two
dressing rooms specifically like they
built it to have two political parties
they do not want more than that they
want to maintain this uniparty of
duality by keeping people like wild
animals it's like sports they want to be
like two teams trying to win well it's
an easy way to have a huge democracy
where people have the air of you know
things going back and forth when in
reality
they're not so here's what happens right
people think that they you know
represent oh this side's fighting for me
but then in reality it's just two sides
that are so going in the same direction
so right now
leftists
are posting
fake tweets
and fake quotes from me that say things
like tim poole has called for the death
of this person or that dude the other
day on tim's show he was saying that
people need to go out and get violent
against this group of people
and they believe it of course that never
happened right so what happens is the
people in that sphere of influence now
typically believe these things and it's
really remarkable when for some reason
conservatives think i'm an atheist which
i've never said and people on the left
claim that i'm
a far-right religious conservative
which i've also never claimed but a fair
point if you want if from your
perspective you want to think i'm more
religious because i do believe in god
but when they say things like
you know tim believes this thing about
taxes and i'm like every time i've
talked about taxes i've talked about
like the need for higher tax brackets
and a stronger progressive tax on the
wealthy even steve bannon has attacked
the rich but they'll lie and make fake
quotes and then in that sphere of
influence which is absolutely split
between two parent umbrellas they all
believe that so when i get into a
conversation with someone on the left
which i recently did
he said something like
you're pro-doxxing tim you would
absolutely dox antifa at a moment's
notice i know what you right-wingers do
what does that mean doxie uh docs means
to publish the private details of an
individual like their phone number their
home their name and i said no i actually
have a huge policy against that and i
often avoid saying names on my show to
to prevent what's called a brigade when
everyone targets an individual and he
was like no i heard you say he's like i
remember during occupy wall street you
were trying to film people's faces and
publish their names
and i said that never happened it was
yes it did everybody knows it because
they lied and made these things up
what really happened is during occupy
wall street i was walking down the
street and i saw three people wearing
masks deflating police tires
and i was filming
so they attacked me and i said
transparency is what matters if
something is happening in public i'm
going to film it if you don't want your
identity revealed wear a mask
so what they did was okay
that's a tenant most people would
actually agree with if you are in the
public and you are causing damage we
have a right to know what you're doing
for whatever cause
you can wear a mask if you want to
protect your identity but if you're in
public during a protest doing these
things people will see you do it what
grounds do you have to violently assault
on someone who happens to have a camera
knowing that they have no winning
argument they changed it and just lied
and said tim poole was trying to take
their masks off and publish their names
interesting discussion and they also the
op the official occupy wall street
account tweeted tim poole just tried to
arrest someone which was an outright lie
it was so egregious
that one of the other activist groups
matches them and said take that down now
like you went too far and they had to
remove it that's what happens when you
have control of the discourse right is
you can propagate whatever you want and
it won't you know like you were saying
with barack obama blowing up an american
citizen and not being properly reported
on
why my mom didn't know about it it's
like
i was working at nbc during obama at the
end of obama's second term and it was
like the degree to which you know these
people had gotten their jobs in the
white house press corps specifically
because they asked all the right
questions you ask a question about that
drone blowing up that american citizen
in that white house briefing you can say
goodbye to asking any more questions to
the you know the press secretary so it's
like
after 40 years of us going like you know
kind of in the same direction left or
right
didn't matter because you had this
institution of the media that was just
wasn't going to question it well let me
ask you a question you asked me about
whether fox news
was was honest
do you think fox news is dishonest
i don't believe anybody
so that's a dumb answer but um
i think i think fox news in the same way
that cnn i think they everybody
exaggerates everything is hyperbolic
so they're in that statement right even
that statement was hyperbolic
there's a really great tweet that i
actually they never let me pull up
anymore because i think instagram got
rid of it maybe because it's a little
bit too close to exposing what's
actually going on let's see if i can
pull it up
there is a a an image that i posted
showing two televisions
one has cbs and one has fox news it was
when gordon sondland was testifying in
the ukraine gate scandal to impeach
donald trump
in his statement he said there was no
quid pro quo
but i felt like there was one
so cbs reports sandlin confirms quid pro
quo
fox news
quote sandlin no quid pro quo the
reality is that the fox news statement
was the correct statement because the
opinion of someone and how they thought
or felt is immaterial to what was
actually occurring at the time yet
people who watched that network
uh well they believe fake news let me
see if i can find it whenever i try to
pull it up on the show it doesn't let me
what was it like when kennedy i mean you
were pretty young but like with kennedy
you know was he like a transformative
like did he upset the discourse and kind
of half the country in the same way that
trump did yes mostly because he was a
catholic
and because he was young
so on the right fox news quote i want
nothing sandlin confirms trump told him
no quid pro quo on the left this is cbs
evening news sondland confirms quid pro
quo
but fox news was right
uh i want nothing was a quote donald
trump was quoted as saying no quid pro
quo and all sandlin said was you know
but i kind of felt like there was one
i'm like okay well what you feel is is
not material to a legal proceeding yeah
the colors are even blue and red it
makes me think of football well that's
what they got us doing they're making us
play political football with each other
but who was against the iraq war and the
wmd narrative at that time cnn and msnbc
were just as on board as fox and that's
what we were talking about earlier which
is like
there there is a certain
you know
no-go zone and it's politically
incorrect to not you know you can't
mention
anything about anything other than pro
uk ukraine same thing during the iraq
war which was like if you're
if you support the hijackers on 911 then
sure you might question the iraq war but
otherwise you know and there was such a
fear from people in the public eye i
remember sitting with dad like switching
between the channels and being like
yeah look see cnn msnbc fox they all say
the same thing about the war you know
why is that because like you said the
left used to be anti-war yeah luke
rudkowski did phenomenal work about 911
and all sorts of evidence that the war
in afghanistan was full of it that all
this evidence that it wasn't what the
mainstream media told us the buildings
fall and freaking free fall it looks
like sometimes and like
nah ian you are you are exactly even
people like tim is like has to yell out
or chooses to yell against but it's like
you can't how honest can
can i go back to feminism for a minute i
want to hear what lydia has to say
because you are of a much younger
generation than me
and how do you perceive
feminism in your
generation so feminism kind of breaks my
heart because i think that most of the
women in my generation have been lied to
i think they've been loot used
politically
and i think that they're told lies to
make them feel good about themselves
earlier today i was looking at
a tweet from a feminist and she was she
compared two different screenshots of a
twitch title she tried to title one
something like women are bad and she
wasn't allowed to twitch which is a
streaming service yeah so they very
carefully monitor what used for titles
she tried to put in the title women are
bad and twitch did not allow it she
tried to put in the title men are bad
that was fine i've done the same thing
with instagram i made a tweet about how
or i commented on instagram that i
thought that modern women were like lost
and instagram immediately took my
comment down i made the same comment
about men as far as i know it's still up
nothing happened it's really weird but
women think that everybody's on their
side and they feel like they're winning
this war but at the same time they're
being introduced like transgender
athletes and men are kind of taking over
these things that were once sacred
spaces of women like
these these spas where women are being
exposed to men in their locker rooms and
all these strange weird gross assaults
are happening and they're like oh it's
fine we're being inclusive we're going
to go along with it because we're nice
and we're friendly and everyone's nice
to us i think that people have really
taken advantage of women's
caring compassionate safety oriented
nature
to get the better of them and to get
their political aims through so this
means things like opening the border
this means things like bringing people
in from other countries instead of
focusing on the people who live here
first and foremost it seems to me like
jordan peterson talks about how we've
never before seen
feminine political pathology we've seen
masculine political pathology that's
when we go to war that's when things get
wild and crazy and bellicose but we
haven't seen the feminine form and i
think this is what we're seeing and i
think it's a different kind of sickness
that we don't really know how to handle
just because it is so new and i think
this might be one of the things that
kind of disorients you about it because
i think that's what underpins a lot of
the problems we see now and like when we
talk about you know feminists want to go
to war or whatever it's true that it's
not all feminists but it's the loudest
ones these are the ones who get
attention they've got the ukrainian flag
in their twitter bio and they are out
there saying we have to defend these
poor children even though it's in the
best interest of americans to stay out
of that well so do you know the the the
greek i don't know if it's a play it's
called lis estrada i don't know if it's
euripides
the women in order to get the men from
stop fighting they just stopped having
sex with the men yeah and that was that
was their power right they say that
women are the neck that turns the head
and this is true women have a kind of
soft power that influences cultures and
i feel like there are
kind of like dark forces that have kind
of manipulated that so that they get
women to do what they want by being nice
by being friendly by saying we're going
to protect queer kids we're going to
make sure that everyone's safe we're
gonna bring all these people into our
country
and because women aren't having children
and they don't have their own families
to defend anymore they're like you know
what that's a great idea let's do it i
have this maternal instinct and nowhere
to direct it and i i think that's kind
of what we're seeing this is what i said
yeah it's terrible aristophanes wrote
liz estrada
so is that your free love movement that
screwed over the women in the long run
because that that
i mean what lydia just what what you
just mentioned in the play
is
you know women using the power that they
have as women which is as the
gatekeepers right to
sex and the free love movement got rid
of that
let me well not really no let me ask you
a question do you think people who are
not citizens of the united states should
be allowed to vote in our elections oh
my god
i think
no
no you think people so if someone isn't
a citizen of the us is tim setting me up
here no no
should should non-citizens be allowed to
vote in our elections i don't think so
well so you're a conservative
welcome i think i am well i think i am i
mean i think that's what that's
happening
i'm getting more and more conservative i
must say i i think it's fair to say that
the modern intersectional feminist
movement wants non-citizens to vote
so
this is all very
disturbing to me it's a lot well here's
the new york times there is no good
reason you should have to be a citizen
to vote
i can easily pull up tons of people i
don't read i think that's the perfect
example though the example that tim just
gave which is the fear that i think you
know like a lot of our generation has
like a lot of my peers is like oh okay
unless i unless i'm following the
current thing unless i'm like up to date
on like you know where i should be on
like feminism and like the war in
ukraine if i say the wrong thing then
they're going to call me
right winger and that's the worst thing
that you can be called you know
pejoratively in like polite societies
but don't you think there's something to
taking all of this
seriously i don't take that seriously
you lose if you take seriously
no no in new york they have granted the
right of non-citizens to vote in new
york city we have this non-citizen
voting rights gain traction as
immigrants vote in an sf unified school
board recall when you don't take it
seriously it happens and it is happening
nonsense but don't let it upset you i
guess
i don't know i i mean we also had this
um rank voting in new york city ranked
choice
which
totally manipulated the vote in my
opinion because it it deluded
the numbers of votes for whomever you
know might have won in my opinion well
right i like ranked choice voting it's
it's not perfect but the the way it
works is you you say you know if there's
four candidates you number one i just i
don't normally have uh a rank for mike i
just want one guy or another well you
only get one
yeah i know but if you're ranking them
and that guy didn't get enough votes
then the other guy gets it because there
were enough votes and if he didn't have
that then well it's better it would have
been a pure voice a more pure voice
well the issue is you know trump and
hillary in 2016
both the most some of the most despised
candidates in history
everybody basically was like i don't
want either but if i don't vote for this
one i'll get the other one right with
ranked choice voting you say yeah well i
don't want hillary so i'll give trump
number you know two but i really want
ron paul so you know if ron paul doesn't
get it at least trump will win wow so it
prevents uh to a certain degree
you know of voting against people though
it but it is important there's a lot of
pitfalls in ranked choice voting because
for similar reasons all it does is kind
of
it pulls down the spire a little bit
but um
what we've been seeing now in the united
states is i mean the title 42 the
borders in total disaster
the the country that millennials have
inherited i would just call a
rubble-filled wasteland and i mean that
figuratively obviously we're extremely
wealthy we have morbidly obese homeless
people things aren't all that bad
but um
millennials are certainly dealing with
extreme crises the the uh
the generation that brought about the
millennials controls a disproportionate
amount of wealth
you know from uh
relative to prior generations they're uh
laden with debt because they were all
told by our parents you have to get you
know hundred thousand dollars in debt to
go to school i was lucky enough to be
like nah i'm not that stupid i won't
fall for that so now
you have millennials who are just
saddled with debt
it is predatory interest rates where
people who have taken a 20 000 loan are
now 10 years later they've paid back 50
thousand dollars and they owe 100 just
really ridiculous numbers i mean that's
that's probably a yeah that's pretty
extreme you'll get like put 20 out 20
years ago you'll owe like 38 at this
point
or something so you owe substantially
more than you borrowed and you've paid
back substantially more than you
borrowed these are predatory and then so
what's happening now is millennials
basically indentured servants in many
many ways are looking at the boomer
generation who own all this property and
keep buying it up
and they can't move so they're getting
more and more extreme they've dealt with
two major economic crises 2008 and now
the pandemic inflation is through the
roof there's food shortages you know the
millennial generation is probably ready
to just burst at the seams yeah mark
give me something give me a little
something yeah little action you got
while you were you know
you had it better than me
[Laughter]
what'd you think tina when the war on
terror began after september 11th what
did you see change
everything went to hell after that
well 9 11 was so
terrible and she was on her way into the
city oh wow i had surgery two days after
no it was the
it was
i told i told my parents that like i
thought something bad was going to
happen for the month leading up to 9 11.
and it turned out uh that they had found
out my mom had lung cancer oh gosh and
uh
yeah they
um you know scheduled the surgery so i
picked up on their negative energy and
then on 9 11 she was going in on 9 12
for the surgery
so on 9 11 they sat us all down in the
afternoon we all got home from school
and we were like is mom okay she's going
into the city oh she's fine they set us
down like your mom has lung cancer she's
going into the city tomorrow for surgery
we're like this is the worst day ever
like you guys you've got 911 and then
you give us cancer like on top of it
what are you what are you doing well i
know you were young too you didn't plan
it that way i was fortunate i guess to
be
21 when that happened and to see the
difference between the world before and
the world after
i never trusted any of it i mean after 9
11. me neither i didn't trust a bit of
that the kids that are born after 9 11
are born thinking that it's normal to be
at war across the ocean and i think
that's twisted people beyond measure
yeah i don't think of it that way but i
guess that's true
and that's everybody's perspective and
that's why when joe biden is running
against trump the majority of uh the
youth vote goes democratic for the ones
that do vote because they're like i
don't know war is normal right oh my
gosh
so when trump's like let's stop the war
they're like no why should we change
that
we like we like getting free oil by you
know blowing up kids right
i think that's something that's
definitely something to it
you're born into it you don't care
so you know i i remember um
my grandpa was talking about social
security numbers and he was saying how
back in the day
you didn't have to get one until you
were like when they first implemented
people are outraged like i'm gonna
register a number with the government
are you nuts and then it was like well
and you don't need one until you're 16.
then it was like well you got to get
when you're five and that's when you're
born you have one when kids are born
into that system they're just like i
don't know whatever
we all have these things so these kids
are born into a world of
a war yeah and some of these kids are
born in like 08 right so you've got
you've got kids who are teenagers who
were born years after the war started
still in it and so then you get donald
trump being like i'm going to end this
and they're like why do i care
yeah the anti-war the sentiment of
anti-war is has slipped well it's it's
not the same it just isn't the same as
it ever was in vietnam they implanted
journalists in with the soldiers and you
would see guys getting carried out on
stretchers and just the most vile stuff
and that was like that was enough to
bring about the consciousness to end
that thing but here they just have dudes
like riding on tanks with a flag waving
a flag and be like we're going to
baghdad they don't see the doors getting
kicked in the people getting
annihilated by the troops which is what
also what was happening
uh
it's been hidden from the people
man i want to put body cameras and
helmet cams on soldiers live stream it i
think people need to share this show
with their parents
because no i i was hanging out with a
good friend of mine over the holidays
whose parents were totally
in disbelief at even the most basic
things i could say like victor shokin
the prosecutor in ukraine was fired
because joe biden threatened to withhold
illegally usaid to ukraine so the
president intervened on joe biden's
behalf and joe biden likely did this in
my opinion because victor shukin was
investigating a company called barisma
where joe biden's son hunter was on the
board earning 83 000 a month and they go
that's all true and i'm like yeah i can
i can show you all the documents i can
show you the court rulings i can show
you the sworn affidavit from victor
shoken saying outright joe biden did
this and they're like but cnn said that
was fake news
it's like well maybe you should stop
watching cnn well i think there should
be a lot more conversation among the
generations you know like this yes
mom's been having she's been having like
just like not a red pill but just like
this like you know how like you have a
pill with little little granules in
there like one granule a day micro
dosing yes
do you remember biden in 88 when he got
caught plagiarizing and resigned did
were you familiar with that at all he
ran for president and then he they were
like oh he's plagiarizing then they
chose dukakis over him
do you remember that no 88 i was in the
midst of having three sons
i didn't know anything dropped out of
pretty much everything else
actually real quick can you tell the
community can you tell the commute story
about your commute um well this was just
this is like it's like
kind of the way that i
wanted to handle i didn't know how to
handle working and
having children and
i had been in my job for eight years and
my son george
richie's older brother wasn't born
he was born after 11 years of marriage
and so i didn't want to leave my baby
and i didn't want to quit my job
so and we lived i commuted from
connecticut so
um
richie's dad bought me a volvo for my
birthday and i put the baby in the car
and took him to new york with me
had a babysitter at the office who met
me handed him over
in the garage and
occupied a space in
in my office building
to uh for his nursery
and every night i'd stop at this i think
it was like a bulgarian deli on the way
and bought two heinekens
strapped the baby in and strapped myself
in and drank two beers and no he had a
car oh he had a car
well dude well i was drinking two beers
and smoking cigarettes and smell car
seat
and that's how i got through you know
through the first three years of his
life different times do you remember it
no that was my older brother that's why
i turned out fine
such an angel yeah i just got an idea
i think i want to hire maybe like five
people
to go um petition in like new york or
chicago or la
and the petition would be for
international immunity for barack obama
over the extrajudicial assassination of
a 16-year-old american citizen and they
would say well look you know obama did
this but we're looking for support to
say that he should be immune from
prosecution
and try and give him a sign
we should film it we'll put it on
youtube it'll be fun
that'd be a lot more effective than
getting yeah that's a pretty good idea
excuse me sir you have a moment we're
we're trying to help barack obama i know
you like well he's a fan you're fa yes
you are come here you vote you voted for
biden right of course you did check this
out so uh back in uh uh you know the
obama era
barack obama ordered what's called an
extrajudicial assassination now this was
when a drone
went to yemen and blew up a civilian
restaurant
now there was a 16 year old american
citizen in that restaurant who died
named abdulrahman al-awlaki
we want to make sure that moving forward
that barack obama will not be charged
with war crimes or
crimes in the united states because i
mean you know killing u.s citizens is
illegal so we're hoping you would sign
this document
i wonder what people would say we could
also maybe get biden immunity from his
uh sexual assault allegations against
tara reid
when he was younger that's a better one
yes funded funded who wants to do the
show we used to do those all the time
like man on the streets yeah during um
the trump years which is like you read a
bunch of obama quotes you know because
the things have swung so far left that
you read a bunch of obama quotes you say
what do you think about what trump said
and then but you know they say it's
terrible and then you say actually
barack obama said that right but this
one will be funny because it'll be a guy
wearing a vest and it'll be called like
you know defend the dems and he'll be
like hi i've got a petition here we want
to make sure obama's immune from
prosecution for the 16 year old that he
murdered please sign here
they'll be like i don't wanna i don't i
don't know i don't know if i should sign
that and be like well you're not a
fascist are you
well who's the last like true anti-war
president then before carter
well before before carter yeah i think
so
yeah people really didn't like it when
the gas went missing you know
the gas gas
the gas went missing i don't know about
that what's the the whole waiting
yeah
so they were like go back to war blow up
people so we can get their oil
let's go to super chats and read what um
the audience has to say
very many people who have commented if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com if you uh would
like to support our work
check out our episode yesterday with
lauren southern where she is wielding a
sword and we talk about
getting pizza in the outback cool it's
actually really cool like the middle of
australia where it's a desert there's
like people living underground and they
have like pizza points i want to go
all right
penumbra syndicate says moon's haunted
can we get a nuke the moon shirt oh yeah
absolutely if jessica's listening let's
get a nuke the moon shirt
we're working on the chicken city shirts
and so far we have a roberto and it
looks really good i so we jessica's
amazing our our graphic designer
an artist and she
made a bunch of different cartoon
versions of our rooster and my favorite
one has him as a triangle and i posted
on instagram we're not going to use it
because i'm like it's out of line with
the
cartoons we're doing but it's it's
hilarious it's like a hilarious little
rooster cartoon i love it
maybe maybe we have to use it i'd love
it too roberto is kind of like he's like
that jacked guy who's like got a huge
upper body he like walks around like
that why are you called roberto
what is it roberto oh roberto roberto
robert oh
roberto roberto roberto yeah he can't do
it
all right roberto
i'm gonna kick him out of power anyway
so yeah there you go oh roberto attacked
him he did uh oh it's more he smelled
you coming i tried to do the coop yeah
he attacked and then richie came back
with the hylian shield yup from a legend
of zelda and he was terrified yeah he
was no i know
cat p says down with roberto all hail
the rise of richie
there we go
and if i have to take it by force i will
oh boy this is war all right the curly
afro says ian the love you have to end
the fed needs to change instead pay
closer attention to the bank of japan
literally the most consequential bank in
the world the japanese yen is nearly in
free fall check out the forex chart
interesting that's cool i'm i'm really
not concerned with breaking up or
destroying anything at this point i want
to create something new but thank you
for pointing that out i agree with that
w falcon says hey tim what are you gonna
have amanda milius and lauren southern
on together i'll be fine are they
friends i don't know i don't know that'd
be super yeah i'm down that'd be that'd
be cool
yeah
yeah
no no i think for the members only one
that's when they're allowed down yeah
that's fair
all right warwolf says greetings crew of
ian cast irl oh ian today is graphene
friday give us your humble and loyal
fans a graphene fun fact and tim please
make some tim cast brand beanies you can
take a 64-sided piece of graphene and
turn it into a ball and i believe that's
called a buckyball
um created by buckminster fuller or or
popularized by the man and you can put
stuff inside it like medicine and then
send it through carbon nanotubes also
made of graphene to their destination
all right nicholas salter says i watch
you almost every single day and i'm
always bored going through youtube
during work outside and being able to
come here right when it starts was
amazing keep it the good work and glory
to chicken city ladies and gentlemen i
have announcement to make we're
renaming it cocktail though sorry
so uh
tim cast irl
is the number two most super chatted
show in the united states
followed by number three fresh and fit
followed by number four riccate uh
rakeda recapable okay law i was
pronouncing wow
number five
the enforcer followed by number six
us chicken city
oh nice okay and i would like to point
out i did i was wrong about that fact
just a minute ago about the grand theft
auto
c60 graphing there are 60 pieces of
carbon in there i don't know how many
seconds not accurate my understanding
maybe i'm wrong but i believe that tim
cast irl is the um
uh
number one
human like live action super chatted
show in the world i could be wrong about
that there may be one
might be but i'm pretty sure everyone
above us are youtubers which is like
animated women chicken city is now
number 31 in the world cluck club
for those who didn't see it i posted on
instagram
the last chicken city stream has 245 000
views
so
a lot of people on twitter are
demoralized and they're like what am i
doing wrong
people love chickens dude do you know
that chickens used to be a religious
symbol
no
people need to understand the power of
chicken here's here's my question
because chickens would lay eggs every
day right it was a symbol of life and
fertility so they used the chicken and
the rooster as like
yeah because they chickens um originated
in southeast asia
the red jungle fowl were first bred to
fight but because they lay eggs every
day you're like you get eggs every day
that's that's awesome they're good eggs
we love eggs and so when it swept across
europe and was brought in people were
like this bird is amazing it doesn't fly
magical and you just give it food it
gives you an egg we want more of these
things okay but so if roberto roberto
is leading chicken city and chicken city
is now like you can't say roberto robert
roberto roberto roberto whoever he is
he's he's clearly not a good leader
because
all this money is pouring into chicken
city
and they're living in squalor i know are
you kidding i mean i think it's
pocketing i think it's all the hentai
and the co the cocaine
if you make me sheriff i'm going to put
an end to that and i'll make sure that
the money gets back into the hands of
the hens and the chickies richie not
only are there no open borders the
chickens
[Music]
says hey should i cancel my membership
here and up my membership at timcast.com
but seriously when are we when are we
talking about how hilarious this depth
trial is yes you should be members at
timcast.com it's better across the board
we're gonna have um i think we're gonna
have like a big announcement next week
i'm really excited about because um
let's just say we
a lot of what we've been working on has
been infrastructure stuff so you guys
are going to be super excited for this
we put our money where our mouth is and
the depth trial is absolutely hilarious
jeez
i feel bad did you see what sort her
amber heard was like looking down and
listening and then she laughs and looks
up and she starts crying and makes her
sad face again can't believe she was an
actor a couple of actors
i think johnny depp is a weirdo but i
think amber hurt is the crazy one yeah
what is going on i've looked so little
into it it's like such nonsense drama of
two people all i saw was a clip of him
shoeing like
throwing everything off on toxic
femininity toxic feminism oh yeah
all right
what does it say jedidian hello tim and
crew thank you for always keeping us
informed can you shout out our dogs
gofundme she has cancer and needs
surgery her name is
moe
is that how do you i don't know how to
pronounce that moquisha you're gonna
have to spell it out yeah uh it is under
m-o-c-u-i-s-h-l-e
mokeshall's surgery organizer is kevin
martin thank you
best of luck for your for your loved one
yeah
always sad
all right
we'll grab some super chits merce cookie
says a woman is a person born with xx
chromosomes and a vagina at birth the
uterus ovaries and fallopian tubes are
important but that alone and the ability
to bear children does not make one a
woman
thank you for the science lesson
i'm not a biologist so yeah i'm not
either sorry no i can't answer that
question
ninja robot says listen to more tool
have maynard james keenan or danny kerry
on the show
uh
weren't they involved with the perfect
circle or something like that yeah yeah
maynard is for sure i don't know about
the other guys dude i just want to shout
out that song judith by perfect circle
because the guitar playing just blows my
mind into this day h is just so insane
it's so good do you know latino no i
don't you gotta get into it i wish i
could that's amazing what's the name of
the band tool okay yeah
but i just love the slide and then like
the weird slow descent oh it's so good
it's so good he has his own wine company
too cool
all right
we'll grab some uh super jitsia raymond
g stanley jr says daryl davis on irl yes
please coming soon coming soon
trying to tell you says the pendulum has
been swinging since the beginning but
it's swinging harder and harder the
things going on now are no longer local
to one place or another the things are
taking place around the world great show
tonight you know the way i describe it
is it's a tower
that every day grows
and as the tower gets bigger it starts
swaying left and right
but once it gets too tall it'll swing so
far left so far right so far left then
snap it just breaks the tower of babel
is that what happened at the base of the
tower it's just swinging they didn't
talk about it collapsing in the bible
they just talked about it going up and
then god scattering yeah i think trouble
but i think about the tower i think the
the birth of this nation started with an
unstable foundation and it's quite
literally that thomas jefferson made a
compromise with slave states because
they needed the support to win the
revolution
as much as many of these northern states
did have slaves there was initially a
provision one of the one of the
statements in the declaration of
independence was that the king had taken
people from a different country and
brought them there to wage war on them
they had to take that out because
jefferson was worried the southern
states which were very dependent on
slavery for their economies or i should
i should very much just say preferred
that and didn't want to do the work
he was like whatever you guys want to
join our effort
that was a big mis i mean
well that was the start of the issue
right whether or not america could have
won independence i don't know but from
that point within 80 years you're in the
civil war because there's like we're at
odds and as more states come in are they
going to be on one side of this issue or
the other okay what about hope that's
that was what was in my mind when we
were talking about left right you know
nobody wants to come on and talk about
it
do you have hope tim i think we're i
think the civil civil libertarian is one
of the easiest way to describe whatever
this is i think i think we're winning
you look at the polls for what's
happening in december and whatever it is
the democrats have decided to embrace is
becoming widely rejected by the american
people
so
we'll see how it plays out maybe it'll
be a civil war but but at that time at
the time that you're discussing that was
the left and the right were hamiltonian
and jeffersonian which in a weird way
were almost you know agrarians versus
industrial
which is where yeah
yeah exactly you know and so i think
then you get the civil war but if you've
got this rickety thing shaking
throughout the generations it just
shakes harder and harder and harder and
then we've built it up so big it's like
on the verge of falling apart again yeah
well
we'll see though another civil war maybe
all right metaphor just one joe biden
stutter away from yeah yeah
vosh says nance is nowhere near any
fighting in fact i bet he's hiding out
in cuomo's basement ah
austin says tim when are you going to
make your own app we actually have uh
the first i think the app is almost done
it takes a long time you know uh
a lesson for most people is no amount of
money can get you something that doesn't
exist yep what i mean by that is
you know if you want to go from new york
to dc
what's the best way to do it if you're
if you're a multi-millionaire what's the
best way to do it if you like i need to
get to dc for this important meeting
what do you think the best way to do it
is speed boat unlimited money
pj
going to an airport going out of the
city going to the airport waiting
commissioning it then you got to have
the plane wait at the hangar when you
land in dc and you're outside of the
city train yeah too far for a helicopter
yeah it doesn't the cost is immaterial
the train is just faster so you're
sitting there with everybody else
doesn't matter how much you're worth not
the bar car
i mean you might prefer a plane because
it's comfortable you know then you sit
in a car and you you know make your way
there
all right tradesman
yeah says hey tim i love listening to
your show as a podcast i had no idea
just how gross the chat was here on
youtube though keep doing what you do
man you are making something amazing i
really appreciate it and welcome to
youtube
i was thinking like we had i was like we
you know we should do for um i wanted to
use chicken city chat as our like
members only chat on the website
but maybe chicken city chat needs to be
chicken city like you know i i knew
chicken city would be successful but uh
chicken city yesterday raised two
thousand three hundred and fourteen
dollars in one day that is 23 chicken
parties
[Music]
people actually come in and just drop a
hundo and be like chicken party and i'm
like
yeah and then roberto is just like doing
lines in the background he's out of his
nose
all that cocaine i'm so excited for you
to just
create some order
he refuses to do it now
all right
it's like voldemort like you refused to
say
raymond g stanley jr says tim ian's
right that felt weird lol but yeah ian
is right his best commercial is the
trident one from the super bowl tina
thank you for coming thanks raymond but
it's an orbit commercial not a trident
or
gum yeah yeah ian was in a commercial
for the super bowl it was really funny i
didn't know they were going to run on
the super bowl
great it's good i'm clipping my nose
here you've got a classic ian's though
right there
yeah so there i was playing with some
graphing and i ended up on a super bowl
yeah really i thought
the morning i shot the commercial
will i am says unlike dancing war does
not require the consent of both parties
we are in a culture war classical
americans did not consent to this war
but it does not matter we are in it
nonetheless yeah i agree and if we panic
that's when they got us
what do you think in multicultural
democracy or constitutional republic i
like the constitution i like rallying
around a piece of paper rather than
cultures and identity politics i think
that or not just the paper but the ideas
that are transcribed and away from us
that we can all kind of revere and
utilize
well that means you are right-wing
maybe today correct you sounded like
mark levin right there oh my gosh the
constitution empowers us
that's my living i have two wings jesse
kelly had a tweet where he said the
constitution is is
not an effect like you've got people who
are like where we believe in the
constitution the other side's like it
doesn't matter does it doesn't it
literally doesn't matter the right the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
so in maryland new jersey and new york
when you're like um hello government can
i have a gun they go no and you go okay
yeah the constitution does not protect
us we protect the constitution yep yeah
and because people are unwilling to live
by and enforce it
there you go oh what was it was it soda
mayor said i don't understand why that's
something the states this why it's a
power the states would have but not the
federal government absolutely insane
everyone vomited in the ninth and tenth
amendment yep yep yep
[Music]
all right eff says have to put my dog
down monday he and i always watch your
show after work and he loves when
everyone gets all hyped up it would be
awesome if everyone can shout out my dog
romanov named after uh black widow since
he acts like a girl peace y'all
good job romanov romanov
all right
grizzle grizzlock says please please
briefly discuss the shift in the overton
window
are you familiar with the overton window
no none at all so within the spectrum of
the political compass like of political
ideas there's a window of socially
acceptable thought that moves around
and the idea is that today it's being
pulled all the way to the left so if you
are a moderate
or a conservative they say you are far
right
you're not but to the overton window
you're on the right edge or outside of
it so that's what happens on twitter
they make rules where they're like
anyone who has a conservative
conservative conservative opinion is an
extremist and they'll ban you who is
overton
uh it was that it was the guy who coined
it i don't know john overton was the
name i think no actually but the idea is
as the left goes further left the center
also goes further left yeah and then if
you stand still the center cannot hold
yes
i'm learning that poem right now
wonderful poem everything falls apart
the center cannot hold
jn says ian you complicate the simplest
things not everything is an algorithm
hope you're simple enough to understand
that much respect crew thanks dude
i hope it was a very extreme statement i
i hope not to complicate everything
keith mccracken says if the fans of the
show really want elon on the show then
y'all should do a massive flood of
tweets of go on tim cast irl to elon i
think it will get his attention i don't
know you know i never do that kind of
stuff
when um i was like the original beef
with joe
where he joe rugged invited me on the
show and then canceled and then i flew i
could flew out he canceled then he
invited me on again then i flew out and
he canceled i was just like dude doesn't
owe me any favors like elon the richest
man in the world owes me nothing and i
don't think tweeting at him is like
i tweet i don't i don't think everybody
just blasting him i thought it was funny
i tweeted at him like hey lion come on
the show i think that's funny and it
might work and he seems like a cool dude
it would be amazing if we had elon and
jack dorsey on the show
so but i i think it's impossible because
jack's on the board of twitter
yes never really seen elon in this kind
of like i mean you've seen him on joe
rogan and you've seen him on like
babylon b
but like in terms of like i mean like
you just asked uh tina you know like
what
you know like these political questions
that nobody wants to answer specifically
because they're hot button issues yeah i
don't know that would be interesting to
hear him you know voice his opinion on a
lot of those things like the i think the
the one thing i really love to bring up
in this in this context is the ahmed
arbory case because it feels like i'm
the only one there's like a small
handful of people who are actually
challenging the results in that case but
even conservatives are on board with you
know what i would describe as gross
injustice
so it's because of the window that
you're talking about which is like well
that's just that's something you don't
talk about i think it's because
conservatives are uh
cowardly like obviously not every single
one but when cal rittenhouse got
acquitted they all celebrated and people
were crying and then when the ahmed
armory case went went down and the
mcmichaels and that other guy got
convicted they were like well you know
we got our win already so we'll say see
the system worked and i'm like are you
super critical yeah the guy who filmed
it goes to prison for the rest of his
life right you're insane critical
yeah yeah
but i i whatever man
you know one day one day people will not
like what i have to say and well
apparently that happens all the time but
whatever
we're going to say what is
people want to live in a fake reality
where they plug their ears and pretend
like something isn't true you can do
that i don't want to do that i think
they're unmotivated so there are some
some cowards and people can be cowardly
from time to time but i think a lot of
people just don't have the motivation
yet maybe it's dietary you know if you
eat crap it's hard to get up and do
stuff garbage in garbage out right
yeah i hate mcdonald's and it's like it
jacks me up shake shack it clears my
whole you know just look at those rips
yeah exactly
rd says richie is so hot
oh we're just talking about music
music my mom is right here jeez come on
richie's thumb is healed
that's right excellent look at that
mobility great so so we have fun flips
on rollerblades we have a three foot
quarter pipe slash launch ramp and a six
foot landing pad
and richie went
very fast and did a front flip off the
ramp but basically cleared the whole
landing landed at the bottom of it and
what happened to your thumb use i
subluxed it
subluxation popped up popped out yeah oh
i did that my mom was like i thought you
said you were done doing stupid stuff
yeah no stupid you mean amazing
right
did you see the video yes it was a great
video it was really stupid
no she took me to a vert ramp when i was
like 11 or 12. i was like this is like
before you got there was like a it's
like a skate quest like map quest for
skate parks and i'm like mom there's a
skate park like
20 minutes away can you take me there
and there were no photos some of them
didn't have the photos on there so i had
no idea what kind of skate ramp i show
up and it's like a 10-foot ramp and i
have my skateboard had like the you know
the longboard wheels on it like so i was
so grossly unprepared i was like 12
years old 11 years old and i'm and i
remember climbing up to the top of it up
the stairs and my mom's at the bottom
like rich you sure about this and i'm
like i know what i'm doing
drop it boom wrist broken the moment i
tried to drop in just fell straight back
snapped the wrist are you okay i think i
broke my wrist
luckily my dad is a doctor so oh my gosh
he walked right over and just pulled it
and said you're fine yeah his thing was
he he would like have me come in for my
cast and then i'd bring in my hockey
stick so he could mold the hockey stick
around oh no that's great she can still
play with the cast on that's wild
all right raymond g stanley jr says how
about a go fund me for billboards in
tennessee you know what i'm thinking i'm
thinking that when they booted robbie
starbuck off of the primary ballot
because they claimed he wasn't a
republican they should earn the ire of
angry people who are outraged over the
corruption of the republicans what was
the grounds for that like what's the
specific republican
but how do they concentrate
you need like vouchers or something but
like robbie more than qualified what was
his district
uh fifth seventh fifth i thought
do you wanna pull up that story on real
real quick i wanna make sure i know who
he is so he's he's is this like he's
he's a he's a guy a friend of ours yeah
yeah he's a friend of the show he's a
republican he's like a populist america
first guy you know like pro workers
rights in a sense not the left
necessarily sense but like you know
pro-trump
and they
booted him off the ballot for the
primary election so he can't
what did you do was an independent
i think we should um
we should show the corrupt republican
party what happens when you you piss off
people who are politically active and
young
and um
i got to figure out how that works and
what the legal like guidelines are for
the appropriate thing to do but i'm
thinking like what buying billboards or
commercials billboards are passive you
want to contact us the people that are
in the offices and you want to contact
their uh their secretaries and you want
to overload them with information so
that they have no choice but to listen
it was 14 vouchers or 14 affirming
vouching people letters that's what he
had right that's what he had
i think they said that he didn't have
enough but he had 14. that's crazy to me
that's so like flagrantly corrupt that's
nuts thank you richie
i i kind of feel like um
i don't know i'm extremely livid about
this because i've been telling people
hey vote in the primaries make sure we
get real people young people active
people to to get involved in politics to
help change this world and then when you
get someone who is prominent respectable
successful like robbie young person they
they they play dirty games to make it so
he can't be on the republican uh the
ballot for the primary
so you know
i i the republican party does not does
not have my vote
i don't like them i've never liked them
i voted for trump only because i did not
like biden and trump had really good he
had proven himself as explained earlier
in the show but if the republicans think
in the midterms they're getting my votes
it ain't gonna happen when when they
played games like this and i understand
this is the tennessee gop i don't care
i want to see how old is he robbie is he
32 34 34.
he's young young yeah i want to see
the candidates for the for the
republican party in west virginia i want
to see them stand up for robbie i guess
they don't need my votes though you know
west virginia is going to go republican
so to be fair he wasn't the only
republican to get kicked off the ballot
my position was too which is not any
better but that was uh morgan yeah
morgan
but uh morgan was because of
you know what some other excuse yeah i
don't know what the excuse is it doesn't
it doesn't matter
i'm i'm i'm legit pissed off that's not
cool
so
i'm gonna i'm gonna be exploring this
and seeing what i can do the most
effective way to uh
i don't know man
i'm not happy about it i think
organizing call call patterns is good
like getting it at a certain time of day
you call this you call this office you
call this office you call this office
take turns do it four times a day six
times a day make sure they know how you
feel be honest and be kind about it but
make sure that they know
well we'll we'll figure something out
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already smash that like button before we
go subscribe i have a super chat i'd
like to read it's from raymond frye it
was directly at me and it kind of moved
me and i wanted to say something about
it he said hey ian hey man i served in
the iraq war as an infantryman we did
not kick doors in and shoot civilians we
went out of our way to save civilians
yes drone attacks suck we did not like
them yet say we're all committed war
crimes or did not try to help people as
a lie raymond i'm sorry if you took it
that way i don't think that i never
thought that everybody there was a
killer or a cruel or a horrible person
it was a friend of mine and they were
talking about the first iraq war in the
90s and she told me very explicitly that
they did kick doors in and kill families
so
there you go thanks if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
if you would like to support our work
it's friday night we're going to have a
lovely weekend and then of course
chicken city will always be live for all
of you to relax and watch chickens big
news lo-fi chicken city beets to relax
to is coming next it's going to be a
youtube livestream where just plays
relaxing music but there will be the
occasional buck buck in there and i'm
not kidding you guys think i'm doing it
we're doing um we're doing cartoons
so uh we're the merch is coming next
there's going to be a shirt for every
chicken character and uh we want to do
consistently like a cartoon with chicken
facts so it's like the weird things that
chickens do we make a fun kid's show
just wait until i carry out my my coo
and then my chicken your chicken facts
become chicken alternative facts and
then like your lo-fi music is just like
i was told it's not family friendly to
have poop and fart jokes what and i'm
like i think so but some parents don't
like it but so one of the funniest
things about chickens
is that they're smart enough not to
drink
water they dump in but not smart enough
not to dump in their water
so the next idea i had for cartoon was
the chickens are like that's a good one
so the chickens are like they're looking
up at the sun and they're going
water and they're like they're looking
at the water and it's you know got filth
in it and they're like it's gone bad and
they're like i don't think we're gonna
make it and then a human comes over and
switches the water out and they go
salvation and they all start drinking
like crazy and then they stand up and
they're like we're saved and then they
must go
then they turn around go the water's
gone bad that's chicken it's kind of
like american democracy yeah
i don't like that comparison
yeah all right everybody
um thanks for hanging out and to uh tina
and her son thanks for coming and
joining us on the show thank you for
having me thanks for having me mom it
like out of your body
and thank you for having me jim would
would either like to shout anything out
i just shout out my mom for giving birth
to me and um also my campaign to uh take
over um chicken city
he's always just like i think the issue
is
as mayor of chicken city there'd be like
labor laws involved like i'd have to pay
you money and roberto i don't know i'm
just grateful that you had me at this
table at age 70 so thank you oh no
worries
glad to have you absolutely appreciate
it
oh geez ian crossland thank you guys for
coming and um
that's about all i got this comic
infinity gauntlet changed my life it's
been sitting in front of me check it out
this is an aquamarine
it's pretty cool it's cool i love you
all richie tina thank you guys we should
do this again i'd love to see you man
this is great to talk extra generational
conversations beautiful bye thank you
lydia yeah absolutely i wanted to read a
very short part of the second coming by
william butler yates is a special shout
out to michael knowles because he loves
this poem this is an incredibly timely
poem that you mentioned and i forgot how
much i love it
okay so it goes turning and turning in
the widening gyre the falcon cannot hear
the falconer things fall apart the
center cannot hold mere anarchy is
loosed upon the world the blood-dimmed
tide is loosed and everywhere the
ceremony of innocence is drowned the
best lack all conviction while the worst
are full of passionate intensity and i
think if that poem doesn't describe
where we're at right now that's the part
i learned on the train yes it's hard to
remember because it's so painful yeah
it's a beautiful poem it's very poignant
and i think that every everybody should
read the second coming by william butler
yates i am sarah patchell it's on
twitter and mines.com i also have sour
patchwood stop me you may follow me
there thanks for hanging out everybody
why don't you head over to chicken city
on youtube you can search for it or you
go to chickencitylive.com it'll prop pop
right up and you can also check out the
cast castle vlog or pop culture crisis
or tales from the inverted world season
2 coming soon we got a lot of cool stuff
in the works i think next week we might
have a big announcement we'll see
infrastructure-wise the stuff we're
built we're working on and joining up
with is going to be really cool so
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
next time bye guys
you